I'm going to put this one here.
I feel like I was like, waiting here, kinda nervous, um, but yeah, also not sure when
I was gonna start.
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
Thinking about my stances, I realized I was going really fast, so I was like, oh, my stances
aren't that great.
Um, thinking about my ki up here, I think overall, I was thinking about each move individually,
kinda focusing on my hand positioning, stances, I think in this moment, I realized I should
probably slow down this particular stance.
Um, was giving me trouble, um, thinking about my block, whether or not I was doing it correctly,
whether or not I was swinging my arm in the right way, the stance switch here, um, but
yeah.
And then, I forgot to take a breath, so at the end, I remember that I need to breathe.
So, as you can see, your pattern is scored, uh, based on the number 10, so out of 10 is
your, is your 1.
Uh, as you can see, it's...
Okay.